Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Oreos in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Hey, everyone. Joe from "Food Wars."
I will not be partaking
in this episode of Oreos
because me and the team are busy shooting
a new season of "Food
Wars" with a new country.
That's right, coming soon to you
it's going to be "Food
Wars" US versus [beep].
While we're working hard
on that, Irene, of course,
is going to step in
over there in New York.
I will, however, stick
around for this episode
and make smart-alecky comments
because that's my brand.
In the UK, Oreos come
in four serving sizes.
As a lunch-box pack of two,
as a standard pack of 14,
as a twin pack of 28,
and as an open and share pack of 36.
In the US, classic Oreos
come in six serving sizes.
As a two-cookie snack pack,
as a six-cookie snack pack,
as a king-size 10-cookie snack pack,
as a classic pack of 36 cookies,
as a family-size pack of 48 cookies,
and, finally, as a party-size
pack of 63 cookies.
The cookies themselves
are supposed to weigh
the same amount in both
countries, 11 grams.
We're going to weigh one
and find out if that's true.
12.4 grams.
We're going to do the scientific method.
We're going to test a second cookie
in case there's any disparities.
Yeah, 11.4.
You know what, I bet it's the frosting.
This one's 11.8 grams.
Yeah, this one's 11.5.
So the average weight is 11.8 grams.
So, our UK Oreo weighed 11.09 grams.
Pretty much spot on what they promised us.
The portion sizes aren't the only thing
that's different between our Oreos.
The US also has more Oreo size options.
There are the mini Oreos,
then five stuff options:
Oreo thins,
classic Oreo,
Double Stuf,
Mega Stuf,
and then The Most Stuf.
I didn't know The Most Stuf existed.
I thought we ended it at Double Stuf.
We kept going.
I have an idea.
I don't know why they haven't done this,
'cause the Stuf is what everybody wants,
at least in America.
Oreo needs to invent Just Stuf.
It is a sandwich cookie: Stuf, Stuf, Stuf.
Check it out!
Just Stuf Oreos.
Perfect. That's all I want.
Whereas our options are
minis, thins, classic,
or Double Creme.
For some some reason we call
them Double Creme over here
and not Double Stuf.
How much Stuf are we actually getting?
Let's dissect a classic Oreo.
2.52 grams.
We're committing to 3.2 grams.
Is a Double Stuf Oreo actually giving you
double the Stuf?
Let's find out.
Oh, look at that precision.
Earlier was 3.2.
So this is 6.
That came to 6.13 for us.
They got a little bit
more. That never happens!
[gasps]
So, in the UK, Double Creme Oreos
actually give you 143% more
filling than the classic Oreo.
While a US Double Stuf has 87.5% more Stuf
than a classic Oreo.
I want to know how much
the Most Stuf weighs.
Oh, wow.
This is excessive.
So, the Most Stuf weighs 11.2 grams,
which is a 250% increase from the classic.
It's very stabbable.
I'm gonna DIY my own giant Oreo.
I don't know if it's gonna
fit in my mouth, but.
Harry Makes the World's
Largest Oreo -- ASMR.
11.
It is about 3 inches. Ish.
It's falling apart, much like me.
You know what has to happen now.
I mean, come on.
"Had to happen"?
"Had to happen," Harry?
This had to happen?
I'm gonna squeeze it down.
There we go.
Yo!
[crew clapping]
God, you need the biscuit, really.
Yeah, as you can see, maybe,
maybe all that stuffing at
once is not a good idea.
Here are all of the UK Oreo products
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Oreo products in the US
you won't find in the UK.
Oreo lends its brand name
to a lot of products.
So we're going to split
this into sections,
starting with the cookies.
That's nothing compared to us.
We have 20 exclusive Oreo
cookie flavors in the US.
We have two exclusive
classic Oreos in the UK,
starting with these ones, which
are strawberry cheesecake.
Can't figure out --
ooh.
It's very good.
Then we have this one,
which is a chocolate
brownie batter flavor.
The flavor of the chocolate filling
kind of gets lost in just
the chocolate cookie flavor.
Peanut butter flavor cream. Creme?
I do think some people put
peanut butter on their Oreos,
so maybe that's where this came from.
The Mega Stuf.
'Cause Double Stuf was
simply not enough for us.
Like, honestly, though,
I can appreciate this,
'cause I always want more of the frosting.
But this is kind of ridiculous, isn't it?
We have gluten-free Oreos.
Lemon flavor creme Oreos.
This seems like a golden
Oreo with lemon filling.
It has the Oreo structure,
but it's like a whole completely
different flavor profile,
so it tastes really good.
[beeps]
[screams]
Oreos are too popular in this country.
We don't need this many flavors.
[beeps]
As we move through this section,
you're going to notice a
bit of a Cadbury theme,
because Cadbury and Oreo
seem to have partnered up
on quite a few products.
The first one we have here
is a Cadbury-coated Oreo.
Now, these are just basic Oreos,
but then covered in Cadbury chocolate,
which, as we all know,
is much better than American chocolate.
They're so good, but so bad for you.
Then, after that, we
have these little bags
of Oreo crunchy bites.
These come as either classic
or as dipped versions.
I'm not really sure how they differ
from just classic mini Oreos,
so I'm gonna open a bag and find out.
Is that not just a mini Oreo
that they've rebranded?
In my left hand, I'm holding
an Oreo crunchy bite.
In my right hand, I'm holding a mini Oreo.
The only notable difference is maybe
that the mini Oreo has
slightly more filling.
I feel like this is just
an excuse to sell you
maybe even less stuffed mini Oreos
at a more expensive price point.
Companies can't get away with this anymore
now that "Food Wars" exists.
Chocolate hazelnut.
This is basically like if
you put Nutella in an Oreo.
Caramel coconut.
I think you would like
this if you like caramel.
Chocolate marshmallow.
Ooh, I think this one does
have something on the biscuit.
That's different.
Oh, it's on the inside.
I thought it would be on the outside.
That'd be more fun, but.
Yeah, you get the chocolate flavor,
but I don't think the
marshmallows really come through.
[beeps]
Is anyone even eating these?
I have never seen a single person
buy any of these flavored ones.
So this feels like a conspiracy.
[beeps]
We have the java chip.
Supposedly there'll be
little chocolate chips.
This is good. This reminds me of, like,
a Starbucks java chip
Frappucino, honestly.
Dark chocolate.
The original was just simply
not chocolaty enough for you.
It matches the biscuit.
OK, I'm actually really
excited about this one.
They're Olympic Oreos!
Aah!
I'm one of those people who is like,
I could have been an Olympian
if my parents had just loved
me enough to, you know,
make it my entire life
and forced me to do it.
You know, as if that's all it takes.
"Red, white, and blue layers
of cream with popping candy."
Oh, these layers are so uneven.
It's funny.
You see this? It's like ...
A while ago, they had
special Fourth of July ones
that had, like, sparklers or something,
and it was basically the same
thing, the popping candy.
I feel like they're kind
of just reusing this.
Oh, wait, this is cool too.
It has the Olympic circles
and the American flag.
You know, the best part
about the Olympics this year
has just been all the Olympians on TikTok,
and then also how funny it
is that everyone's like,
"We're only patriotic about
how funny and hot they are."
If any Olympians are watching this,
I am in fact single. Thank you.
When did "Food Wars"
become Irene's dating app?
She didn't say which Olympians, though.
So, like, the Canadian curling
team's coming after her.
So watch out.
The next one, which is
still kind of a cookie,
are these Cadbury
Crunchy Melts Oreo Creme.
Now, these are kind of big,
more traditional chocolate chip cookies,
but then filled with
a layer of Oreo creme.
I will say the packaging
made me expect a lot more
of the Oreo creme in the middle there.
It's a very, very thin layer.
I'm really disappointed by that.
I was -- I had high hopes for these.
The texture of the cookie is way off.
Ooh, salted caramel brownie Oreos.
They're really just turning
every possible dessert
into an Oreo at this point.
But, again, I have never
seen a single person
buy one of these.
If you are someone who buys
these, please let me know.
'Cause I think it's a
conspiracy at this point.
Ooh, this one also is a double layer.
We have a light brown layer
and a dark brown layer.
Ooh, and then there's salt on the biscuit.
They really elevated this one.
It's like a gourmet Oreo.
I actually really like
the salt on the biscuit.
It comes together really nicely.
Again, this is weird.
Carrot cake. Who thought of this?
Carrot cake's hard to get right.
Tastes like ginger with
just, like, nice icing.
So I actually like these,
but that's 'cause they don't taste
like the advertised flavor.
[beeps]
I'm doing really bad, Shirley.
I'm trying not to cry, I think?
I'll be alive.
I don't think the Oreos will kill me.
Actually, the Oreos might kill me!
I can't believe this is
what's gonna take me out.
It's gonna be the Oreos.
[beeps]
Chocolate peanut butter pie.
How many variations of chocolate
peanut butter do we need?
I will say, they are creative, right?
It's not like they just,
like, blast it with flavors
and it looks the same.
At least they look fun.
[beeps]
I thought the Oreos would
make me feel better.
They made me feel worse.
I was betrayed by the Oreos.
[beeps]
Limited-edition s'mores.
Graham-flavored cookies.
These are the golden Double Stuf Oreos.
It's literally the non-chocolate
version of a regular Oreo.
Aah.
I have an announcement to make.
Golden Oreos are the best Oreo.
That's right, the best.
These are the best.
Look at me.
Look at me, YouTube commenters.
This is the best Oreo there is.
I have access to the Food
Insider YouTube page,
and I will delete your comments
if you disagree with me.
This is the best Oreo.
Amazing.
So, there's also three
fudge-covered flavors,
classic, dark chocolate, and mint.
There's also these Oreo thin bites
in original and white fudge.
So these are basically mini
Oreos covered in chocolate.
And, of course, the Oreo ID,
which are customizable Oreos.
We decided to decorate
it with white sprinkles
and put Joe's face on it since
we missed him this episode.
I guess you could call them
J'oreos.
[drum sting]
That's such a good idea!
Why don't we have that?
That's such a funny, like,
party gift, wedding favor.
Just a lot of potential there,
and I kind of wish we had that.
Look, it's Joe!
"Ha, ha, ha, ha.
I'm in LA, and I eat food and do things,
and I have a podcast."
I don't have a podcast.
I am the last human being on
the planet to have a podcast.
Comment below what my podcast should be
and who I should have on it.
Sorry, Joe. I'm gonna
cut your face in half.
I didn't think I would be
saying this of all people.
It's just a lot of sugar.
It's too much sugar.
Yeah, I don't want these.
Joe, you can have them.
All right, let's take a look at these.
Yeah, these don't taste like Oreos.
These aren't very good.
Sorry. I taste terrible, apparently.
Then we have a section
I'm really excited for,
which is the frozen dessert section.
We'll start with these,
which are Oreo ice creams
with an Oreo cookie coating.
Ooh.
Hm.
It's not the best ice cream I've ever had.
Very sweet and a bit, like, foamy.
OK, the cone's pretty good.
I'd say this would maybe get
better the more you go down.
I think less of the ice cream on the top,
and more of the cone.
The next ice cream option is this one,
which is the Oreo ice cream
with Oreo biscuit pieces.
In the UK, we can also just get a tub
of Oreo-branded ice cream.
Now, ones which I've had before
and can tell from experience are very good
are these ones, which are the
Oreo ice cream sandwiches.
Mm.
Then we're back to the Cadbury partnership
with these Cadbury-coated
stick sandwiches.
Our Oreo desserts in the US include
Breyers Oreo Chips Ahoy ice cream
and Friendly's Oreo
cookies ice cream cake.
What!
See, this is a good dessert combo.
This makes sense.
You're adding the Oreos
to an existing thing.
Wow.
Ugh, ice cream cakes are
always so hard to cut.
Cake!
[crowd gasps]
Ta-da.
And we weren't able to get these,
but there's also Klondike
Oreo ice cream sandwiches,
Good Humor Oreo ice cream bars,
and Good Humor Oreo cones.
Then we have a bunch of
exclusive chocolate options,
which are, again, mostly Cadbury.
This one is a dairy milk Oreo sandwich.
This one is also available
in the form of Cadbury bites,
which is just bite-sized
pieces of their chocolate bars.
Then we're on to the one in the middle,
which is the Cadbury Big
Taste Oreo crunch bar.
If milk chocolate isn't your thing,
then they also have a Cadbury
Oreo white chocolate bar.
Our final chocolate bar is this one,
which is an Oreo Milka
Mmmax chocolate bar.
Milka is just a slightly
different chocolate brand
here in the UK.
Then we have a couple of
options for baked goods,
including this Oreo muffin
and this Oreo doughnut.
I mean, if that counts as a filling,
again, a little bit underwhelming.
I know I ate that from the
bottom, like a psychopath.
I don't do that all the time.
This end bit looks slightly filled.
They put it on the box.
It's supposed to look like this.
That's what you call false advertising.
If you're going to go for one of these,
probably go for the muffin.
Then we have a couple more
miscellaneous products
just to round out.
Here are our miscellaneous Oreo items.
We have the ready-to-bake pie crust.
And then the instant
pudding pie filling mix,
which is cookies and cream flavored.
So these go together.
This is the no-bake Oreo dessert kit,
which is basically these
two items in a box.
The first one is this,
which is a Cadbury Oreo
hot chocolate powder.
Now, I'm fascinated by this one
because when I was
buying it on the website,
it had loads of one-star reviews
saying it tasted horrible,
so obviously we now have to try it.
I'm going to use my colleague
Charlie's wonderful mug,
which I think he got in a charity shop,
which is celebrating
the marriage of a couple
who we don't know.
Buchi and Wumi, if you're watching this,
I hope you've had a happy marriage.
Four heaped teaspoons of the powder
into your boiling water,
which is what I have in here,
and we should end up with a delicious
Oreo-flavored hot chocolate.
So let's go.
Now I'm just gonna stir
for about 40 minutes
and then see what we end up with.
[beeps]
Protect me, Buchi and Wumi.
[coughs]
Wow, OK. Um.
The immediate taste you get is chocolate,
which you expect,
but then, like, a second after every sip,
something just kind of
punches you in the face,
and it's not very pleasant.
Moving swiftly on from the hot chocolate,
we have this, which is
an Oreo split-pot yogurt.
Yes, it's pronounced
"yaugh-gurt" and not "yo-gurt."
Get it right.
Do Americans have Müller corners?
Because I ate those all the
time growing up in the UK,
and this is the exact
style they've gone for.
Basically, it's like a split-pot thing
where half of it is yogurt,
and then a little corner of
it is a topping of some kind,
the idea then being
that you just crack this
and deposit all the toppings in.
This really does take me back.
I would have some kind of Müller corner
in most of my pack lunches
when I was in primary school.
That's really tasty.
And then last but by no means least
we have these, which are Oreo O's.
Now, it's an Oreo-themed breakfast cereal,
and it comes with these chocolaty loops
and then some vanilla-flavored disks.
We have the Oreo cereal,
and these look like the UK version,
but without the white puffs.
And then we also have Funfetti
brownie mix, cake mix,
and frosting with Oreo pieces.
And, lastly, these are
the Oreos Handi-Snacks,
Oreo cookie sticks and cream.
Oh, my God, no.
These look like --
you know those cheese and cracker snacks?
This looks like the Oreo version.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it looks disgusting.
There's, like, a pool of oil
or something right there.
Here are all the ingredients
in a classic Oreo
in the UK.
That makes a total of
at least 18 ingredients,
possibly more if multiple
flavorings are used.
Here are all the ingredients
in a classic Oreo in the US.
That comes to a total of
at least 17 ingredients,
again dependent on the flavorings used.
So a UK Oreo actually contains
more ingredients than a US Oreo.
The UK has a few ingredients
not found in the US.
Take sunflower lecithin,
which they use in
addition to soy lecithin.
Some people prefer to
use sunflower lecithin,
as it's extracted naturally
via cold pressing,
whereas soy lecithin tends to
be extracted using chemicals
such as acetone, like
in nail-polish remover.
Soybeans are also more commonly
genetically modified than sunflowers,
and concerns over this
have also driven people
away from soy and towards sunflower
as their preferred source of lecithin.
In the US, we use high-fructose
corn syrup in our Oreos,
compared to the UK's
glucose and fructose syrup.
You'll see this in a lot
of American products,
as it's a cheaper
alternative to actual sugar
as a result of the US
producing a huge amount of corn
and tariffs on imported sugar.
There's limited evidence that suggests
that high-fructose corn
syrup is worse for you
than normal sugar.
Nations which use it tend to have
higher rates of Type 2 diabetes
than those that don't.
What about Oreos with some
more controversial ingredients?
Like birthday cake, for example.
In the UK, we actually call
those birthday party Oreos,
but they are effectively the same thing.
In the UK, we color the
sprinkles with spirulina extract,
red beet juice, and turmeric extract.
Whereas in the US, we
color our sprinkles with
Yellow 5, Blue 1, Red 40, and Red 3.
Fans of "Food Wars" will
recognize Yellow 5 and Red 40
as two food colorings
not often seen in the UK.
If they are used in the UK,
manufacturers have to add a warning
that they, "May have an
adverse effect on activity
and attention in children."
We love our artificial
and potentially dangerous
food colorings over here.
Red 3 is actually one
I don't think we've seen
before on "Food Wars."
It's otherwise known as erythrosine,
and it's a dye used to give
foods a reddish-pink color.
It's not commonly used in the US,
with manufacturers usually
opting for Red 40 instead.
The reason for its low popularity
is its association with
certain health effects.
It was partially banned in the US in 1990
after research showed that
it caused cancer in rats.
Its use is restricted
in the European Union
due to the same concerns.
While the European Food Safety Authority
did say that humans weren't
at quite the same risk
of tumors that rats were,
they still set a limit of 0.01 milligrams
per kilogram of body weight
per day for human consumption.
As a result, the only food
that Red 3 can be used in
in the EU is candied cherries.
It's not banned in the
US, but it is restricted.
It can be added to foods,
but it can't be put in
cosmetics or external drugs.
So you can put it in your
body, but not on your body.
Other things to look out for in the US
include the carrot cake Oreos,
which contain caramel color.
According to the state of California,
a byproduct of this can cause cancer,
birth defects, or other reproductive harm.
The UK's Oreo is actually
healthier in every metric
other than saturated fat,
where the two are tied.
Classic Oreos aren't too unhealthy,
except for the sugar content.
You would only have to eat 11 US Oreos
to hit your entire daily sugar allowance,
which is just under a third
of your daily calories.
What about the least healthy
Oreo in each country?
Well, in the UK, it's
the Cadbury-coated Oreo.
Here's the nutritional
information for just one of them.
If you eat just five of these,
you consume 98% of your daily sugar
and 55% of your daily saturated fat.
And I'm pretty sure if
I started eating these,
I would be eating more than five.
Our least healthy Oreo?
It's the fudge-covered
dark chocolate Oreo.
Five of these cookies would be
110% of your daily sugar allowance
as well as 112.5% of
your daily saturated fat.
I don't know if I want to eat these.
These are aggressive.
I feel like Joe could probably
eat, like, the entire box.
I'll try one.
It says "mmm."
I don't feel "mmm."
We don't need to cover
everything with chocolate.
[sighs]
Something about this seems wrong.
It actually is good. Very chocolaty.
It tastes -- oh, my God, the
filling is chocolate too!
Joe can have these.
Joe, you can eat these.
Irene, I don't want those.
Don't send them over here.
Off to LA!
Ah, there.
No, thanks.
Well, the monster,
the monster one was 11 Double Stufs,
so that's, like, 20,
that's literally 22 cookies, Shirley.
And then I had at least three or four,
and I took several bites of others,
so I have had at least 30 to 40 cookies
if you do the math, honestly.
And then you add that
I didn't eat breakfast,
and then you add that I'm in the midst
of, like, five mental breakdowns,
and so we are in an interesting place.
Just gonna roll away.
[laughing]